You've been playing a game your entire
life without knowing the rules. And
that's why you keep losing. Everyone
thinks success is about working harder.
But here's the truth. The hardest
working person you know is probably the
most frustrated. Reality operates on
hidden rules. Three invisible levels
control everything. Level one, what
everyone sees. Level two, what actually
happens. Level three, why it happens.
Want the cheat codes? Reciprocity.
Give first without keeping score and
watch the universe keep a ledger you
can't see. 1% better daily. That's not
365% improvement. It's 37 times better.
Not percent times. Your environment
makes decisions for you. Put a book on
your pillow. Sleep in gym clothes. Make
good choices the lazy choice. Most
people push doors that open by pulling.